I'm looking out at all of these faces
and I'm assuming that many of you have
probably arrived here with some
preconceived notions about the American
revolution.
I'm assuming that at least some of you
are sitting there and in the back of your
mind you're thinking declaration of
independence, a bunch of battles.
George Washington,
a little bit of Paul revere thrown in
and all of those things are going to
appear in the course.
But obviously the real American revolution
is a lot more complex than that.
It's more than a string of
names and documents and battles.
And as a matter of fact, in many ways,
the American revolution wasn't just a war.
If you went back to the mid 18th century,
went back to the period of the revolution,
or maybe just after it,
and you ask people how they
understood what was happening.
Many of them would tell you that the war
was actually only a minor part of the
American revolution.
Some would tell you the war actually
wasn't the American revolution at all.
And you'll see, I should mention that
the syllabus is finally up online.
So it's therefore you.
Um,
but you will see when you look at the
syllabus that at the very start of it,
there are two quotes and I want to read
them here because they make this point
really well.
So the first quote is from a letter by
John Adams and he's writing to Thomas
Jefferson in 1815 and he's heard about
the attempt to write the history of the
American revolution.
So this is what Adams has to say about
that as to the history of the revolution.
My ideas may be peculiar,
perhaps singular,
but what do we mean by the revolution?
The war,
that was no part of the revolution. Okay,
there's the moment where you go hook.
It was only an effect
and consequence of it.
The revolution was in
the minds of the people.
And this was affected from 1760 to 1775
in the course of 15 years before a drop
of blood was drawn at Lexington.
Okay.
So there we have John Adams saying that
the war was actually no part of the
revolution. It's a pretty famous quote,
but it's a pretty interesting statement.
Now I want to, I want to mention here, um,
and it's very early in the course for me
to have more few into liking John Adams.
And I'm going to talk more about
John Adams and a few minutes,
but I won't mention here since
I've just read that quote. Um,
if partway through the semester you
decide you're just dying to read dead
people's mail, which is basically
what historians do for living, um,
a great volume to read is actually the
letters that Jefferson and Adams sent
back and forth to each other
over the course of their lives.
They've all been pulled together into
one volume and the best part of that
volume is the end section.
The letters in which these guys were
writing to each other in their old age.
So you have these two founder figures,
former presidents,
and they're just basically
letting it rip in these letters.
They're talking about everything.
They're talking about,
all the things actually you probably
wouldn't talk about normally our religion
politics, who they hate, who they like,
what they thought of the revolution,
what they thought their own presidency,
what they thought of the other guys
presidency, the top 10 founder funerals.
Actually there's a little section,
although it's,
I think it's the top three founder
funerals, but it's a weird,
really interesting range of stuff and
it's just these two people really excited
about the fact that they've retired and
all they need to do now is write to each
other and really get to know each other
better. So it's a, it's a great volume.
It's edited by Lester Kappan. Last name
is ca PPO, and if you're interested,
okay, so that quote I just read is
actually from that series of letters,
Adam saying that the war was no part
of the revolution. Adams does say,
well maybe my ideas are
a little bit peculiar,
but he's not the only one spouting that
kind of fun. So here's Benjamin Rush,
who I guess in a way you could
say it was doctor to the stars.
He's actually this renowned doctor from
the revolutionary and early national
period, and he had a lot of
high placed political friends.
So here's Benjamin Rush writing in 1787
there is nothing more common than to
confound the terms of the American
revolution with those of the late American
war.
The American war is over.
But this is far from being the
case with the American revolution.
On the contrary,
nothing but the first act of
this great drama is closed.
So there you have Benjamin Rush saying
that, boy, this is a common problem.
A lot of people mix up American revolution
with American war and they're not
just one in the same thing. The war
is over. The revolution goes on.
And Russia saying this,
even as late as 1787 it's four years
after the treaty that ended the war.
We're hitting into constitution
territory and to rush.
The revolution is continuing.
So what do these people mean?
Well,
in part they are expressing part of what
this class is going to be exploring.
They're basically suggesting that the
American revolution represented an
enormous change of mindset
as loyal British colonists.
Right,
long standing,
loyal British colonists were transformed
gradually into angry revolutionaries
and ultimately into Americans.
Like John Adams suggests the beginnings
of this transformation predate the
actual fighting and like
Benjamin Rush suggests,
it doesn't just come to a close
when you sign a peace treaty.
So when you look at things
from this broad view,
the revolution actually
becomes the beginning of a
period in which the American
nation was really inventing itself,
and this is a really dramatic kind
of invention. You have an a sense,
we're just little
pipsqueaks at this point.
So you have these little pips weeks
and they're actually saying, okay,
we reject monarchy. We're going to
turn towards a democratic republic.
They're saying,
yeah,
well we know the power has been
at the imperial center forever.
We're going to turn our backs on that
and pull power into what's basically the
margins of the British empire.
They're turning away from an assumption.
The few are in power, and they're saying,
well,
what if we try putting the many in power?
Those are pretty dramatic changes
and they aren't. Of course,
the only changes people, colonists began
to think about themselves differently.
It's really easy to underestimate the
degree to which individual colonies at
that time were really like little
independent nation state colonies.
They were not United in
any sense of the term.
There wasn't any tradition of colonies
being able to communicate between each
other.
It was actually in some ways easier to
communicate with the mother country then
to get some kind of news up
and down the Atlantic seaboard.
Colonist often knew more about the mother
country than they knew about people
from other colonies. They, when you
look at correspondence from this period,
people often refer like New Orleans where
we'll refer to southerners as though
there are people from a strange alien
country who have weird excellence.
It's hard to know what they say.
They dress so strangely.
It's amazing to think
about the differences,
the degree to which colonies really
stood alone in this time period and this
idea that there really is pretty much
no reason to assume that these colonies
would have been able to join together.
That's pretty much going to be in the
first two or three lectures of the course.
What we talk about as we try and get a
sense of who these colonists are and how
they're ending up moving
their way into a revolution.
So this scattered group of independent
colonists gradually came together to form
one United nation. Not
the goal, but the outcome.
Given everything that I just said,
you can see why this idea that there
might be a United nation is actually a
pretty big surprise.
You can see why a lot of people
assume that it could never work.
You can actually also assume why a lot
of people might not even have liked it as
an idea and you can even see why after
the constitution goes into effect and the
government is getting underway.
Even then,
people were really just not sure this
thing was going to work. They really,
they referred to it as an experiment,
which is really how they viewed it and
it's amazing when you look at letters
from the 1790s you'll see like these
little throwaway comments like a,
if this government lasts more than five
years, here's what I think we should do.
Okay there it's a completely weird mindset
and it's not something that we would
assume is there, but this is pretty
much a high stakes experiment.
So this class is going to explore this
big shift in mindset and the war will be
at the center of this shift and it's going
to do this from a participant's point
of view.
It's going to really grapple with how
things made sense at the time to the
people who were there. And I'm going to
go more into that in a minute or two.
I want to talk for just a second about
how the course is organized and have just
for a minute or two about some
of the readings for the course.
The course is partly
chronological and partly thematic.
So we do proceed along. We follow the
narrative of events of how things evolved.
All those nasty act people protesting
have a war to try to figure out what to do
after the war. We do follow
that sort of trajectory. Um,
but we're also gonna once in a while,
step back and look at the big picture
so that we're not just following events.
We're going to be always putting events
in context and the readings for the
course going that same direction.
We're going to read Gordon Woods
radicalism of the American revolution,
which is a really great overview of
this time period and also presents an
argument.
Obviously if you could tell from the
title that the revolution was really
radical.
Some people agree with
that and some disagree and
actually one of the discussion
sections is geared around
discussing that very idea.
And by the end of the course you'll
probably have some pretty strong ideas,
not necessarily agreeing with mine,
but based on what you've read and
what I've said and what you thought,
you'll probably have some strong ideas
about how radical was the American
revolution.
Um,
we're going to be reading Robert Gross
is the minute men and their world,
which you can hear is right along
the lines of what I was just saying.
It really gives you a sense of what it
was like at the time for people who ended
up doing things like fighting at Lexington
and Concord. We're going to read,
um,
Bernard Bailyn's faces of revolution,
which includes an array of chapters on
different people who played a major role
in the revolution as well as chapters on
the ideals on the ideology or basically
the logic of American independence.
And um,
Bailyn is really well known as sort of,
he wrote this amazing book on the ideology
of the American revolution and what
you're going to be reading.
He basically took the,
a big meaty chunk from that book,
the part that everybody really focuses
on and put it in this book faces of
Revolution Revolution.
So we will be reading that as well as
part of the readings for the course.
We're also going to be reading
Ray Raphael's a people's
history of the American
revolution, which does just what
the title would suggest it does.
It looks at how different kinds of people,
native Americans,
average rebels, African
African-americans, loyalists, women,
how all of these different
people have different types,
experienced the revolution.
And then in addition to
reading historical scholarship,
we're going to be reading some
of the literature of the period.
We're going to be reading Thomas
Payne's common sense, which I love.
How many of you who've read common
sense before, a good number of you,
not kind of sort of, you?
Um, I love common sense.
I think it's an amazing piece of writing.
Um,
and I think when you
read it for this course,
you'll get a sense of why it had
such a huge influence at the time.
Um, we're going to read some essays
from the federalist written by Alexander
Hamilton and James Madison and John J,
but we are not going to read them as
prompts. You may have read them before.
You may have encountered the federalist
essays as the ground of authority on the
constitution.
Right?
How could it not be that when you have
founder type guys talking about the
constitution and they were the guys
who were at the convention? Well,
the fact of the matter is the federalist
essays weren't intended to be an
objective document.
They're actually really subjective and
we're going to look at them in this
course as what they were written to be,
which is a really big commercial
advertisement for this new experimental
constitution.
They were actually trying to sell
people on an idea and because of that,
as we'll see when we read
that for this course,
there are things in there that maybe are
a little bit exaggerated and things in
there that maybe aren't talked about in
great detail in one or two things that
probably aren't really true but
it wasn't a good cause. Right?
These guys are saying, I really think
this constitution is the way to go.
Let me say something that's going to
really calm you so that we can go ahead
with this experiment.
And of course we're going to be reading
the declaration of independence.
We're going to reading the constitution,
we're going to be reading a lot of
documents and letters and other kinds of
assorted items to really give
us a sense of the period.
And at one point I'm even
going to bring in, um,
a newspaper from the period so
that we can actually look at it.
And get a sense of how people are
getting news of the war at that moment.
A lot of these documents we're going to
pull from a book called major problems
in the era of the American revolution.
And it's a,
it's a nice collection of
primary documents in essays
about sorta related themes.
I'd always makes me laugh when I say that
title because it's part of a series of
books and the books are major
problems in the revolution,
major problems in the early national
period, major problems in the civil war.
So basically all of American history
appears to be a major problem,
which kind of gives me pause.
But despite that, uh, I,
that's a nice collection of things
and we'll be using that for the class.
So that gives you a sense of how the
course is going to flow and what these
readings are going to do.
Which brings me to the portion of the
lecture that I'm going to call Freeman's
top five tips for studying
the American revolution.
And I want to explain before I launch
into them, what the heck. I mean, um,
basically when I was preparing this
lecture and thinking to myself,
what do I want you to know
about right at the outset,
before we even start talking
about the revolution itself?
And I ended up with a list of things that,
as I talk about them here may seem
obvious, but the more I talk about them,
I think the less obvious they'll appear.
And they're actually really important
to consider in a course that deals with
something like America's founding.
There's a lot wrapped up in that.
Just that phrase, I mean, just think about
the phrase, right? The founding fathers,
the founding period,
you just can see the capital letters.
You don't even need to see it in writing
and your mind, it's always capitalized.
We assume a lot of things
about this time period,
and it's sort of an iconic period when
you think about American history. To us,
a lot of the people and events in this
time period and the documents at this
time period are kind of
what America is all about,
which is understandable.
But to think about the
founding period as historians,
we need to think differently. We need
to be aware of all of those assumptions,
all of that cultural baggage that we
bring when we're looking at something like
the American revolution,
we need to be aware of them and then
we need to get past them so that we can
really begin to understand the people and
events of the revolution for what they
were.
And that's how I got to Freeman's top
five tips for studying the American
revolution. Five things that you should
bear in mind when studying this period.
Five things obviously that will be
useful to remember throughout the course.
Basically all of them aimed at just
shaking the assumptions right out of us.
And the first tip is actually
really related to that point.
The first tip is avoid the dreaded
revolutionary war fact bubble.
And what I mean by that is you're going
to be sitting here and over the course
of the semester you're going to hear
a lot of familiar names and events,
Boston Tea Party, George Washington,
the greatest hits of the revolution,
the things you know and love
and learned in high school,
they're all going to be here. And hearing
all of these beloved greatest hits,
you may be tempted to sort of sit back
in your seat and drift along the happy
familiar events. Ah, the story
of the American revolution.
I love the story of the
American revolution. Well,
American revolution,
but there's a different story
of the American revolution
besides all these names,
facts and dates that you probably
have arrived here with in your head.
It's a really good dramatic story,
but it's not a string of facts.
So thus the fact bubble, it's not
a fact bubble. The revolution,
obviously it's a lot more than that.
And you need to sort of almost be aware
of the facts and then allow yourself to
step back and look at the big picture.
And John Adams and Benjamin Rush and
others like them would have been the first
to tell you like the facts in
a sense are the least of it.
So that's tip number one is don't get
lost in the dreaded revolutionary war fact
bubble w which I have to say,
it makes me,
makes me think of the first
time that I taught this course.
I was actually a brand new professor and
I had just come to Gail and it was my
first course and it was my first lecture
in my first course and I'm actually,
it was in Connecticut Hall,
which for those of you who don't know,
um,
dates back to the period when this course
is talking about and was Nathan Hale's
essentially his dorm. So there I am,
I'm like a brand new professor, Gail,
and I'm teaching a course
about the revolution and
it's in a building that dates
to the revolution. So I'm having sort of
a wow Yale moment as it is and I'm off,
I'm giving, my lecture
isn't, I'm really excited.
I give about three of them and someone
raises their hand after about three
lectures and they have a kind of a puzzled
expression on their face. I said yes.
And he says, um, excuse
me, professor Freeman,
what are we supposed to be memorizing?
Where are the facts and dates, right?
So as a new professor, my
first impulse was, darn,
I forgot the fat suit dates.
I got it wrong.
But actually the fact of the matter
is they're not the star of the show.
Certainly dates are not
the star of the show.
There are dates you're going to have to
remember. So don't think easy street.
There's not a date I have to know.
There will be some dates,
but this isn't a story about dates.
It's obviously something a lot more
interesting and a lot broader than that.
Okay.
Avoid fact bubble tip number two,
think about the meaning of words.
Now on the one hand,
this may seem really obvious and you
may be sitting here thinking, oh great,
this is going to be a semester of Freeman
saying, what does revolution mean?
What does war mean? Which would be
really, really, really long semester.
And that's actually maybe there
might even be a point where I say,
what does revolution mean?
I even kind of sort of said it already,
but that's not what I mean when I
say think about the meaning of words.
What I really mean here is be careful
what you assume about words because what
seems obvious in meaning
to you now probably meant
something really different in
1776 or 1787 and I want to look at one
example because it's a really striking
one. And that's the word democracy. Okay?
So sitting here in this
room by our standards,
democracy is a good thing,
right? Democracy is a good thing.
Every once in a while it's a professor,
you'd say something and then you think
with her about how it's going to look in
your notes. So you'll have all
these notes and then it'll say,
democracy is a good thing.
Really sophisticated class we're teaching
here at Yale. Um, but to us it's good.
And two people in the founding generation,
not so much.
They weren't so sure about it.
To them the word democracy signaled a
kind of government in which every single
person participated personally,
not a government based on representation.
We're talking mass politics in the
minds of most people in the founding
generation.
Just the definition of what chaos was.
So just listen to a sentence in one of
the last letters written by Alexander
Hamilton, 1804 the night before
his dual with Aaron Burr.
So he's like sort of speaking to
posterity in case he should die.
And this is what he writes.
In this letter I will hear express,
but one sentiment which is that
the dismemberment of our empire,
I love the fact that America's an empire
in 1804 will be a clear sacrifice of
great positive advantages
without any counter balancing,
good administering,
no relief to our real disease,
which is democracy. Okay, are
real disease is democracy.
Alexander Hamilton.
Now admittedly Hamilton might not be the
shining example of the point I'm trying
to make here because he's
not exactly Mr Democracy.
So you wouldn't really expect him
to be clapping his hands for it.
But now listen to Thomas Jefferson who
maybe you would brand as Mr Democracy.
So Jefferson in 1816 is chatting away
with someone in a letter about what
America is trying to do and whether
America is actually achieving it.
And he says,
actually democracy is pretty impractical.
He can imagine it in a town, but
outside of one town, it just won't work.
Again,
really clear.
Their sense of what that word means is
really different from our sense of what
that word means. Now Jefferson
immediately goes on to add, um,
that democratical I democratical.
But representative government is a good
thing, right? A democracy, not so much,
but democratical, which is
a great, the 18th century,
they're always adding ecole
onto the end of things,
which could end perfectly
happily with the sea.
This is a great 18th
century sounding word.
Democratical democratical representative
government is a good thing,
but democracy not.
So the moral of the story is don't
fall into what I call democracy speak.
Don't write papers where you toss
around terms like democracy, liberty,
freedom,
without really thinking about what you
mean and what they meant as Americans.
We're used to tossing those words around,
but to early Americans,
if you think about it too early American
slave holders, words like liberty,
other such words have a much more
complicated meaning. So tip number two,
think about the meaning of words,
which brings us to tip number three.
Remember that founders where people
now as I was writing this, I thought,
oh that's another one of those things
I don't want to see in people's notes.
You know, democracy is
good. Founders are people.
Such a highfalutin course. I'm teaching
here. Um, again, sounds really obvious,
but what I really mean here is we tend
to forget this pretty simple fact.
We forget that the founders were people.
We assume that they were these all
knowing demi gods who are sort of calmly
walking their way through the
creation of a new model nation.
We kind of deify them.
We put them up on this sort of awe like
founder mountain top of American history
and it's really,
it's easy to do.
I mean sometimes just listening to
their words or reading their words would
inspire you to want to do that.
Here's a random phrase I thought,
what can I write here that would be sort
of inspiring founder talk and this was
the one sent two sentences that I came
up with just cause they always stick in
my mind because they
sound kind of amazing.
This is actually Thomas Paine common
sense in the middle of it. He writes,
we haven't in our power to
begin the world over again.
The birthday of a new world is
at hand. Okay, that's really,
that's inspiring stuff.
I mean that's,
that's fine writing but that's inspiring
talk and it's supposed to be obviously
cause pains. Trying to convince people
that independence is a really good idea,
but these kinds of words,
they sort of glorious rhetoric shouldn't
block out the simple fact that the
founders were people, they were regular
human beings. They were well educated,
they were thoughtful,
they were sometimes well meaning
they were sometimes hardworking,
maybe sometimes not so much.
They were people aiming high.
They were people who did feel
responsible to posterity,
but still they were people and to me,
this is one of the really exciting things
about history generally and about this
time period specifically we're talking
about people trying to figure things out.
We're talking about the most
basic things about America, right?
It's existence that it is a nation,
that it has a constitution and we're
looking at people trying to figure out how
all that stuff is going to be
created and how it's going to work.
These are people who are scared.
These are people who make
dumb mistakes on occasion.
They're figuring it out as they go.
The history of this period is a
history of decisions of various kinds,
and these were hard decisions and they
were being made by people who did not
know the answers.
They're making it up as they go along.
I think that's just fascinating when you
just read their correspondence and get
a sense of how much they're really
in the dark. There's a, actually,
when you read letters from the period,
a lot of them say the same thing, right?
When the government launches,
um,
I think George Washington
and James Madison and a,
a Pennsylvania senator almost
say the exact same thing.
It's almost like they
went into a room and said,
so how will we express being scared of
this moment? Ah, here's a good sentence.
They all say, basically, I feel
like I'm walking on hollow ground.
I feel like the ground's going
to break beneath my feet.
They've just launched this constitution
and they all are sort of standing there
on the national stage thinking,
what if this all explodes?
Like do we actually know what we're doing?
That's a really fascinating part of
this period to me. Now, of course,
sometimes people did try
to figure out the answer.
So in a wonderful sort
of enlightenment way,
and my favorite example
of this is James Madison,
who prepared himself ultimately for the
constitutional convention by studying
all governments across
all time. You Imagine, Oh,
I better go study all of government
ever to get ready for this convention.
But he does. He has a great sort of
enlightenment thing to do. He's thinking,
I will now discover the eternal
patterns of politics, and he's thinking,
if I can do that, then I can reach
for the best I can avoid the worst,
and whatever we're going to do
when we make a new government,
maybe we're going to actually do
something better than what's come before.
So there's a logic to it as,
as ambitious as it is,
there's a logic and he
was serious about it.
So it wasn't even just wondering what
happens if I read a lot about government,
he actually was serious about it.
He even made a kind of a little chart
in which he listed the governments and
then listed pros and cons like,
well, what do I think of Sparta?
I mean he sort of amazing, I
mean across all time, you know?
So I love the fact that he did that
founder like thing to do, but there are,
you see a person,
a really intellectually ambitious person
trying to figure things out. Like how,
how do we know what make, what's his
constitution supposed to look at?
Like how are we going to figure that out?
Okay,
I'll just study all of
government and let you know.
So when we talk about
the American revolution,
we're talking about people and this
course takes this idea really seriously.
Part of what we're going to be doing over
the course of the semester is looking
at the revolution from the
vantage point of participants.
Trying to see how people
at the time understood the
events unfolding around them.
How did the colonists understand
themselves as British subjects?
How did they feel about the British empire
or about the king or about parliament?
How did they come to put
Americanness in the foreground?
How did rebelling against
their own country makes sense?
And that's something I think we also
tend to forget about the revolution.
We think of it as our war you, it's us
against them and them equals the British,
but of course we were the British, so
it's something that you don't think about,
but people at the time,
certainly in the 1790s people referred
to this as the civil war because that's
what it was.
It's just not the way we happen to
think about it because in our mind we've
already traveled down the road and we're
already us. But in their mind it was,
it was in a sense brother against brother.
It was us against us.
So we're going to try to keep that sort
of thing in mind as we explore how the
events of this time made sense at
that time. And I will say here,
we are not going to
forget about the British,
so we're not going to have
a Patriot centric course.
The British have a logic
to what they're doing,
whether they're making policy or
whether they're fighting battles.
And we will definitely look at the logic
of what the British are doing as well
as what the colonists are doing.
Now I will admit right here up front
that I will be offering you a sampling of
really arrogant British
quotes about crude colonists.
And I'm doing that partly because
there's just so many good,
really arrogant quotes about American
colonists that I can't resist sprinkling
them through my lectures and I can't
resist that so much that I have to hear
that I just randomly added in because
I have a reason to and so I will.
But it's just,
it gives you a sense of how at least
some of the British were thinking and
looking at, you know, really these
little upstarts on the margins of empire.
So random, arrogant, British
quote, number one. Um,
and this is from a customs official.
American colonists are a most
rude, depraved, degenerate race.
And it is a mortification to us that they
speak English and can trace themselves
from that stock.
Wow.
Even English is a problem, you know,
that's a, that's a statement. Okay.
Arrogant quote number two.
And this one I picked us because
it's about George Washington and you,
it's hard to imagine people saying
something arrogant about George Washington
who seems to be like
Mr. Symbol of authority.
But here's another British
official official who met
with George Washington and
then wrote back home about
what he thought. And he says,
somehow,
and I can't,
how he's learned the basics of how to
behave in a court society. It's like,
Ooh, that must have been a
really fun interview too.
If that's the attitude this guy had.
So there'll be a sprinkling of that
because at dramatic moments in the war,
there's always someone who steps forward
and offers that point of view that said,
we are going to do justice to
the British side of the dispute,
to the logic behind the
policy that they were making.
Because it's not as though they make
a bunch of dumb policies that make
absolutely no sense and we're righteously
outraged. And then there's a war there.
Policies made sense to them.
They didn't happen to always
make sense to the colonists,
but that made sense to them. And the same
thing goes with British battle plans,
which looking back in the long view of
time when we start talking about them
might seem a little goofy,
but there's actually a lot of logic for
what they were trying to do when they
were attacking the colonies.
Oh, and I will also mention, um,
I guess I probably don't have
time to talk about it now.
When I was preparing this lecture,
casting around,
trying to figure out what
will I put in the lecture.
I don't know how I came across it,
but I discovered the battle of new haven.
Did anyone know about the battle of new
haven? Because I did not know. I mean,
I know there's like hostilities around
and I don't know if there's like Yale
Lore that of course you're
all sitting there saying,
well of course we all know about the
battle of new haven, but I don't know.
I'm the only one who doesn't know
about the battle of new haven. Um,
but it's actually, it's a good
story. I'm not going to tell it now.
I'm going to leave you in suspense.
It will appear when we start getting
into the fighting of the revolution.
But let me just give you the sneak
preview, which is, it doesn't five.
The prep involve the president of Yale
College with a gun in his hand running to
fight the British. So it's a, it's
a Yale moment that we have. Um,
so I will talk about the
battle of new haven. Okay.
So we aren't going to be looking at
a story of good guys versus bad guys.
We will be reconstructing
opposing points of view,
trying to figure out how those
points have you made sense.
And then obviously we'll be able to step
back and say what happens when you put
those two opposing points of
view in contact with each other.
So tip three founders are people,
which brings us to tip for,
we're not just talking about founders.
The revolution was not just
a quiet conversation between
a bunch of guys wearing
wigs and knee Britches,
right?
We sort of have this image
that the revolution is guys
and short pants with wigs
in a room doing this, you
know, the entire founding,
I think in our minds or it looks like
that, right? So that's not the revolution,
right? That's not what happened.
We're talking about a revolution,
a popular uprising by vast numbers of
colonists fought on American ground by
Americans of all kinds.
And it meant different things
to different kinds of people.
This is not to say that the founders
aren't important far from it.
And as you will gather very quickly
in this course, I love these guys,
but I love talking about these guys.
I love writing about these guys.
So I'm certainly not saying
who cares about founders,
but what I am saying is that they're
not the only ones who mattered.
They didn't have their own revolution
while everybody else watched.
We're talking about a popular revolution,
grounded on the ideas and actions of
people throughout many different levels of
society. Now, somewhat conversely,
this brings us to John Adams.
As I promised at the beginning, John Adams
was coming and here's John Adams. Um,
you'll be hearing from him more than
once this semester and actually you've
already heard from him once. So I
can promise it. That's true. Um,
this isn't because I think the John Adams
is the most important figure from the
period. It's not because I think
that he's always right. In fact,
the reason I quote him a lot
is he's a brilliant blunt,
really direct commentator with,
and this is all important.
You almost need a drum roll here.
He has a sense of humor.
John Adams has a sense of humor.
It's not everyday that you find a founder
with a sense of humor. I can vouch,
there aren't a lot of chuckling founders.
Certainly on paper there's not a lot of
chuckling going on among the founders.
Probably in person there was,
but on paper,
not a lot of them commit humor
to paper and John Adams does.
He's even self deprecating sometimes,
which nobody wants to be self deprecating
on paper when they know that they're
going to be a founder.
But John Sometimes is,
and I'm going to offer one
little tiny dumb example.
First thing that popped
into my mind when I thought,
well what am I going to say to
show down out of sense of humor.
So this is actually from that same
series of letters in their old age when
they're writing back
and forth to each other.
So Adams is writing to Jefferson and he
signs his letter with this John Adams in
the 89th year of his age
too fat to last much longer.
It's just not typical founder Tom.
George Washington is not
signing his letters that way.
But you know Adam's commits
that sort of stuff to paper.
What that means is not only is he blunt,
direct and intelligent,
but he also even gets
to be humorous as well.
So in atoms we have this
sort of cantankerous,
sometimes bemused, more often
irritated, occasionally self aware,
sometimes really not stubborn book steeped
event experiencing action taking tour
guide.
He's not going to be there all the time.
They're going to be long stretches of the
course where we don't find John Adams,
but he's definitely gonna
make repeat appearances.
And in the middle of the course will
even get to tell a really good story,
which he actually basically wrote down
and said, let me tell you this story.
So that's, you know, as a historian,
what's better than historical characters
doing exactly what you want them to do.
Here's a cool story on the revolution.
You can quote it in your lecture courses.
Good.
Oh,
this actually makes me think of
another John Adams related thing.
Before I get to tip number five,
which I will get to, I'm partly,
I'm curious about this and partly
I want to mention something.
How many of you saw the Hbo
Mini Series on John Adams? Okay.
Goodly number of you. Um, I,
I mentioned that for specific reason. Now
I will say I, I, I of course watched it,
um, and the period when it was airing
with a really interesting period for me
because as an 18th century historian
with maybe the only time I've ever been
culturally relevant to popular culture,
I was like, it's my moment, right?
People coming up to me and saying, I got
a question about John at him. I'm like,
wow, this is great. Um,
so it was an interesting moment when
people actually were thinking about John
Adams.
Um,
and I will say also I watched it with a
few historians and we were prepared to
throw popcorn at the screen and we ended
up pretty much liking it and we were
surprised about halfway through. We
all looked at each other and said, Huh,
it's actually pretty
good. So I don't, I mean,
of course there are always things at
any kind of TV or movie production about
history gets wrong. So I won't say that
there's nothing wrong in it. However,
there is one thing that is wrong and I'm
going to mention it because if you have
pictures in your mind from the mini
series as you sit here in this course,
it could be a bad thing to
think that they are accurate.
And what I'm talking about is actually
the F, I think it's the first episode.
It is of course, the first episode and
that's the episode where like, you know,
the revolution is beginning and you see
people milling about sort of with fists,
right? That represents the revolution.
You see the beginning of the revolution,
the bizarre thing about the way that
they depict it is apparently according to
the producers of this mini series,
if there was something happening in
the early stages of their evolution,
John Adams apparently was there. Boy,
they're shooting at Lexington and Concord.
Adam's racing across the countryside
to get to Lexington and Concord,
Boston massacre,
John Adams staring at,
so the idea is really that John Adams
still now it's like never off his horse
riding around Massachusetts trying to
be an eye witness to every historical
event. Now I understand that probably
the people who made this thought,
how the heck are we going to
communicate Boston massacre?
Lexie didn't conquered this is a film
about Adams and we can't like say what
items over here while we know turned
to random people out of field shooting.
So I understand how narrative wise
why they needed to do this. But um,
Adams was not at every store pickle
event in the revolutionary war.
Many and he definitely had an
insider's view of the Boston massacre,
but he was not everywhere
in Massachusetts. Okay. Um,
that oddly enough brings me to tip
number five in the Freeman guide.
And tip number five is
remember contingency.
Again, obvious thing, but
something we don't think about.
People at the time didn't
know what was going to happen.
So Adams could not race to places where
he didn't know the things that happened
yet something might be
happening at Lexington.
People didn't know what
was going to happen.
Think for a moment about all of the things
that we assume about the revolution,
we assume that the colonists were
right and that the British were wrong.
We assume that a
revolution was inevitable.
We assumed that there was broad agreement
at any one time about what should be
done. Right? Of course, we
need to declare independence.
Of course the collars are going
to win the war. Of course,
there should be a national union.
Those are all before the things that
I think we do assume and that's,
that's a lot of assumptions.
That's a lot of of courses,
but in fact it's important to remember
that people didn't know what was going to
happen.
You really need to allow for contingency
because literally what they assumed was
anything can happen.
Anything can happen. Again.
One of the things that I love about this
time period is that the emotions are so
heightened.
If you're in an atmosphere
where everything's up in
the air and you're in the
middle of a revolution or you're trying
to create a government and you literally
don't know what's coming
next and anything can happen,
maybe I'll get hanged by the king.
Maybe I'll get shot going home.
Maybe America will hate the constitution
so much they will throw rocks at my
head. I mean, I don't know.
What they were thinking, well,
maybe the constitution will
last for days and then collapse,
whatever they're thinking.
The fact is because they literally
think anything can happen.
Anything can fall apart at any second.
The emotions are really raised and it's
why a lot of the rhetoric in this period
is so extreme. It's not that these
guys are like trying to be dramatic.
They actually are dramatic.
They're feeling that this is
a dramatic kind of a moment,
and I don't think you get that sense.
I don't think you get that idea unless
you remind yourself about contingency,
but the fact that there are
no predetermined outcomes
and that anything can
happen. I think particularly when
you're studying a revolution,
it's really important to remember
contingency and we will discover what
contingency means in this time period
over the course of the semester,
and I will end there. I will see
many of you perhaps on Thursday,
I will probably know next week better
about the reality of when we'll be meeting
for discussion sections.